12345678 sis beep boop beep boop hey so
we have uh instead of Jackson we have
our good friend to clacks mijnheer today
you have any words for the audience um I
don't know why I'm here I'm actually
duct taped to this chair well I had to
get one of you guys to sit down and play
doom 3 somehow you kept going naw man
will be grey we could just not play doom
3 it'll be like this hilarious running
joke just play doom 3 damn it fun the
Union Aerospace Corporation is the
largest corporate entity why do all
sci-fi games start the same way and then
defense contract because they're all
based on the same inane to biological
research it's always gotta be static and
other size data converse and letters
dead space start this exact same way but
a red faction and doom 3 happened at the
same time so like there's this huge like
um are saying like in the same timeline
no like they're happening like down the
street from each other is revolution
against a corrupt government on one part
of the on one part of Mars and then just
write the other direction there is just
fighting giant monsters from hell hmm
seems awesome that would be great every
in every sci-fi thing after wall that
was a cool shot hey looks all right look
every character looks like they're made
out of like cardboard that was like
taped together you can see the seam in
their head like the line or separating
the two halves of their body it's so
weird look it's creepier than the
monsters from hell we've got you things
are you accept
yeah it's totally it
you're not as much of a dick is Jackson
so this is way difficult like do you
want me we did it to be the dick I want
the deed I mean I want Oh what excuse me
my god no choice true like look at that
guy look his head is made out of he
looks like a stop sign I'm gonna replace
his face with a stop sign for the entire
video the damage every time you see that
one guy this guy was possessed by Satan
cuz his eyes were so weird yeah hey how
come everyone gets a cool helmet except
me 2003 what's wrong with your face
what's wrong with your face whistle it's
like he has like 80 tumors in his head
oh oh oh oh god I kaisers the sensor I
gotta put something hilarious over that
how you put on subtitles going on scan
ready I got stand here right what's he
saying you say we have a mixer instead
of [ __ ] scanning us should I not move
around too much think so so you don't
have any bio weapons in you ever see Oh
what the [ __ ] it's a Robert oh it's
robert it hey wake up [ __ ]
Dead or Alive you're coming with me robó
cola kind of name is that does does the
can come with like a small robotic body
and does it have sentience oh no here we
go well that's way lamer come on don't
advertise this and then give me this the
[ __ ] okay there's I'm gonna awkwardly
look around the ceiling this is your
personal data assistant a lip Jackson
you'll need oh I forgot you're not jack
from areas if you get clearance for god
I miss Jackson normally he'd just be
here screaming about something and I'd
be yelling at him and threatening to
like physically harmonix and died of his
mental state being too oh no my name is
visible on that damn it they're always
trying to get me man up thank you for
your blubber is totally not ah be with
that new detention coming to check I'll
gaga's blood yeah that's why she win his
lip sing Billy I left there stop sign
hat on breaking work that would do that
guys I he's totally a demon trying to
think of a celebrity that he looks look
you can see the line on his forehead of
like something to me that is the
cardboard that he is constructed of what
bigger budget can you get me one they're
all in boxes in the garage I'm afraid
you'll give me nothing okay tc's getting
a soda for us this cutscene is annoying
hanging out with him this like oh yeah
oh this is the bud light commercial over
again look at those textures I just want
to eat all those pixels all those
mangled garbled pixels spokesperson
stated increased he got recently Jackson
and found nude in an oxygen tent which
he believes will give him sexual powers
guys get his last name sorry it's the
other Chinese guy it's the same guy he's
just yeah they said he just lost it
shipped home this week hey steve blum
gained another no-show guys toy look
like they can arm wrestle one another to
like just do it guys come on placing
bets on this one hates do it shifts wait
do it oh yeah this game this game this
is next-gen everyone this is the games
the ps4 deserve oh no it's brighter in
here then when the window was open well
damn it now you were Asian this whole
time thirsty burst it will we go back
what all right so thirsty burst is like
sprite and robo Cola is like coca-cola
no we got pepsi and we got coke right
there like the two warring brands and
they're constantly fighting for
supremacy this place just happened to be
sponsored by both brands and [ __ ] like
what does this have to do with spit is
that a portal level oh look you get the
the companion cube and throw it into the
portal here this will be fun to at it
and then ah that's a shotgun I think
yeah totally yeah no no that's the
future portal gun sir whoa whoa I
thought this guy was gonna execute me
ways last names homes Susie Sherlock
Holmes his first name starts with an S
it was me all along hey hey what you
gotta do yeah shoot me [ __ ] took marine
Khmer shoot me marine report to command
is how know that guy looks more like
dune guy
then the doom guide that you're playing
at why does doomguy not look enough like
doom guy maybe it's like that's the
original doom guy and I'm second doomguy
his long-lost son my name might as well
just be Seamus O'Connor all riley
O'Brien O'Malley McDonald just have all
the Irish names just all of them oh I
got a video disk why is that disk bigger
than his torso what are blu-rays out is
this some kind of hipster space station
where we still run everything off laser
discs what the what where's that guy's
face let's go easy Nicolas Cage not the
bees the bees don't revolt his face on
my face it also like exactly in the day
some people would pay for that Jackson
you know what I'm talking about quality
medical care I know you're watching this
right now you should feel bad cuz you're
not here playing this game with us
you're over somewhere playing
blood-borne like it's like a scrublord
like a smeg moment oh wow oh you hit me
you guys saw that right and I'm making
that PewDiePie money already secure your
pistol for it okay open the door over
the door I won't get my stuff we'll put
the damn door yeah bap yup yeah yeah sit
down grab those other guns what other
gun there are other guns there in the
box ground junction ah quick evac what
better way to see the Martian surface
then you run across it man this doesn't
have nearly the level of condemned punch
in oh yeah keep in mind civilians are
working yet
don't get excited she [ __ ] her power up
oh [ __ ] I've stolen his soul and my soul
I mean PDA why don't you crawl your
friends dead down here do you guys going
on here sure you looks like you're in
the barrel today hey buddy haha get it
his name's fri buddy don't know if I can
really help you whoa Jesus it's
Nosferatu walk oh my god kill it kill it
with fire her how did he he really was a
vampire I'm just really a skel tag come
on man I need to walk that way sneaking
up on people you every dick acid video
games